face à l'urgence la patience a ses
limites l'immense défi que représente la
vaccination d'un continent entier fait
craindre à certains membres de l'union
européenne que le processus s'éternise
pour la slovaquie ce doute poussé les
autorités à se fournir hors du cadre de
l'ua et le choix s'est porté sur le
vaccin russe spoutnik vais dans ce pays
où le taux de mortalité face au coc u19
est l'un des plus élevés au monde
vous pouvez voir derrière moi le premier
envoi des deux millions de vaccins
spoutnik vie que nous avons commandé à
la russie j'ai je pense qu'en respectant
les délais les approvisionnements ont
promis la russie prouvera qu'elle est un
partenaire stable sur lequel nous
pouvons compter en ces temps difficiles
l'autriche de son côté anticipent
l'avenir en se penchant sur un
partenariat avec israël et le danemark
pour se doter de vaccins deuxième
génération indépendamment de l'union
européenne l'agencé européenne des
médicaments est trop lente a approuvé
les vaccins et il y à des goulets
d'étranglement dans l'approvisionnement
de la part des sociétés pharmaceutiques
nous devons donc nous préparer à
d'autres mutations et ne plus dépendre
uniquement de l'union européenne pour la
production de vaccins de deuxième
génération
bruxelles qui pour sa part appelle à la
patience et se défend face aux
nombreuses critiques concernant la
politique vaccinale des 27
le fait est que nous sommes en plein
déploiement des vaccins et des
stratégies de vaccination dans toute
l'union européenne qui je vous le
rappelle compte 450 millions d'habitants
et non quelque chose comme 10 millions
comme israël vous savez donc il faut
garder le sens des proportions en ce qui
concerne le défi que nous devons relever
par rapport à un pays en particulier
fait ce n'est donc pas comme si vous
pouviez prendre un modèle et simplement
le maître vous savez le coller sur
l'union européenne et dire que c'est ce
que vous devriez faire à l'heure
actuelle seuls près de 5% de la
population autrichienne est à peine 8%
des danois ont reçu une première dose du
sérum anti qu'ovide